[Music]
all
hey hey look at me look at me
look at me you want to play games you're
playing with the wrong you
got to do man you're going to make me
mason look at my mother
you want to play games you never get
disrespected
i don't remove your
[Music]
can you stop pulling the handcuffs on my
wrist
don't listen
you're not stronger than me man i'm
letting you know that all right let's go
we're gonna take a seat
so just get in the car
all right just get in the car can y'all
just tell her to stop okay get in the
car get in the car
all right i'm getting in get your feet
in
hey hey look at me look at me
look at me you wanna play games
you're playing with the wrong
you're gonna amaze me
never get disrespected
just let it be
and i'll see you in about five minutes
all right so what i don't know what